clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi tu as lu romain ça
va prendre un tournant
je sais ce qu'il en compte la voix des
mots les sons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes sans doute déjà au courant si
vous vivez pas dans une grotte l'euro
commence demain aujourd'hui
si vous regardez cette vidéo le
lendemain de sa sortie hier
si vous regarde vous allez peut-être
vous retrouver entre potes pour regarder
les matches vous avez sûrement chanter
vous avez mangé des petits trucs sympas
et peut-être que certains d'entre vous
vont parier sur le résultat
alors on va éclaircir les choses
d'emblée oui on va parler de ça mais non
je vais pas vous donner des tips pour
gagner à tous les coups
je peux comprendre que le type de la
vidéo vous ai laissé croire que si mais
en fait non non on va parler des paris
sportifs et de ce qu'il faut faire pour
que ça reste un loisir et que ça
devienne pas un problème c'est un vrai
sujet parce qu'en france près d'un
adulte sur deux et un mineur sur trois
reconnaissent jouer au moins une fois
par an alors déjà avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet on va commencer par
rappeler un truc les jeux de hasard et
d'argent
c'est interdit aux mineurs soyons clairs
mais pourquoi en fait
il ya deux raisons à ça en fait la
première c'est qu'il faut avoir une
certaine forme d'auto discipline et de
maturité pour garder le contrôle quand
on joue et vous allez voir c'est
important on va en reparler
et ensuite parce que plus on commence à
jouer jeune plus on augmente le risque
de dériver vers des habitudes et des
pratiques qui peuvent poser problème et
ça aussi on en reparle donc comme plein
d'autres trucs
il faut attendre d'être capable de gérer
et puisqu'il faut bien fixer un âge baas
et la majorité donc 18 ans c'est comme
ça mais nous on va s'intéresser aux gens
qui ont le droit
d'après les études récentes de
l'observatoire des jeux
la grande majorité des gens plus 80%
joue de manière occasionnelle
ça reste un loisir donc pas de soucis
mais pour certains d'entre eux c'est
plus problématique
on estime qu'on est un joueur très
créatif quand on joue de temps en temps
et que le reste du temps à mon avis elle
et on dit que le jeu devient
problématique quand il a des
conséquences négatives sur différents
aspects news dans ce dernier cas de
figure il ya plusieurs niveaux des
joueurs à risque faible qui représente
moins de 11 % des gens qui jouent au
moins une fois dans l'année mais aussi
des joueurs à risque modéré pour 4,4
pour cent d'entre eux jusqu'au jeu
excessif et là ça concerne 1,6 pour cent
des joueurs donc on considère qu'ils
sont 6 % à avoir une pratique
problématique mais les chiffres sont en
augmentation donc ça mérite qu'on se
penche un peu dessus d'autant que ça
peut déboucher sur une addiction
les jeux de hasard et d'argent c'est
même la seule addiction sans substance
officiellement reconnu une addiction
sans substance c'est une addiction non
pas un produit comprend mais à une
pratique mais on va reparler bientôt de
ça dans une vidéo sur les addictions
donc je vais pas développer sachez juste
que ça existe on va faire un petit
parallèle avec un truc qui est plus
connu du grand public pour que vous
compreniez bien les enjeux
imaginons vous
un verre ou deux avec des potes une fois
de temps en temps juste pour le plaisir
pas de souci tout voilà maintenant si
vous buvez de plus en plus de coups de
plus en plus souvent votre consommation
devient problématique voire excessive et
si vous êtes dépendant c'est à dire si
vous pouvez plus vous empêcher de boire
c'est devenu uniquement en vrai c'est un
peu plus compliqué que ça là je
schématise mais encore une fois on se
parlera de ça plus en profondeur dans ma
prochaine vidéo bon alors bien sûr avec
l'alcool il ya tout un tas d'autres
problèmes qui se posent comme les effets
nocifs sur la santé physique qui sont
hors sujet là on parle juste du
mécanisme qui fait qu'un truc qu'on fait
pour se faire plaisir
ça devient un problème si on gère plus
sa consommation d'ailleurs ça marche
avec plein d'autres trucs comme les jeux
vidéo par exemple la majorité des gens
jouent pas ce qui kiffe et il passe des
bons moments mais ça peut devenir
envahissant si on maîtrise pas le temps
qu'on y passe encore une fois
officiellement c'est pas une addiction
mais l'organisation mondiale de la santé
oms a ajouté récemment dans sa
classification internationale des
maladies ce qu'ils ont appelé le trouble
du jeu vidéo et qui correspond pile à ça
ne plus pouvoir s'empêcher de jouer au
point que ça prend le pas sur toutes les
autres activités et que ça a des
répercussions négatives sur la vie
quotidienne
alors c'est quoi le point commun à tous
à eybens et la perte de contrôle tant
que vous faites les choses pour le
plaisir c'est ok et c'est le cas de la
majorité des gens mais quand vous
n'arrivez plus à vous en empêcher et que
ça prend de plus en plus de place ça
devient un problème pour être un peu
plus concret dans le cas qui nous
intéresse comment on se rend compte
qu'on a un problème avec le jeu on va
faire le point avec quatre signes qui
doit vous amener à vous poser des
questions
vous jouez plus d'argent que vous
devriez par exemple vous jouez plus
d'argent que vous aviez prévu au départ
vous jouez plus d'argent que vous pouvez
vous le permettre vous rejouez pour
essayer de gagner ce que vous avez perdu
voire vous emprunter de l'argent pour
pouvoir continuer à jouer ça c'est
vraiment un cynique et associés 2 vous y
passez plus de temps que vous ne devriez
et vous en avez conscience
en gros vous n'arrivez pas à vous en
empêcher et ça se fait au détriment
d'autres trucs importants dans votre vie
votre travail votre couple vos amis
vos loisirs vos obligations etc 3 vous
avez perdu le côté récréatif
vous jouez plus par plaisir mais par
besoin vous perdez de l'argent ça vous
prend tout votre temps mais vous
continuez soit pour vous refaire soit
parce que c'est plus fort que quatrième
et dernier signe qui doit vous alarmer
vos proches vous font des reproches ils
voient bien les conséquences négatives
sur votre vie il voit bien que vous
jouez plus que vous devriez et peut-être
même que vous essayez de le cacher il
vous trouve moins présent irritable
s'ils essayent d'attirer votre attention
là dessus posez vous la question si vous
voulez en avoir le coeur net je vous
propose de faire un test pour faire le
point sur votre pratique à vous je vous
mets le lien dans la description comme
ça vous serez fixe alors se rendre
compte de ça c'est bien et si c'est le
cas
faites vous aider je vous mets des
ressources dans la description de la
vidéo mais le mieux c'est quand même
d'éviter d'en arriver là
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir vous
connaissez mal mais alors comment on
fait et bien la bonne nouvelle c'est que
la première étape c'est bon pour vous
c'est fait ouais pour éviter un problème
il faut avoir conscience qu'il existe et
vous maintenant bah c'est ok vous savez
ça c'est la base mais évidemment ça
suffit pas donc voilà cinq conseils
pratiques pour garder le contrôle
si vous jouez le plus important c'est de
toujours vous assurer que vous jouez
juste par plaisir
si vous sentez que ça vous stresse ou
que ça commence à jouer sur votre moral
ou votre humeur
c'est que c'est plus qu'à rester
vigilants et gardez toujours à l'esprit
que vous pouvez perdre c'est le jeu ma
pauvre lucette
fixez-vous des limites en termes de
temps passé mais aussi en terme de
budget si besoin vous pouvez utiliser
les réglages de modération sur les sites
de jeux en ligne ne jouer que ce que
vous pouvez vous permettre de perdre là
encore fixez vous un budget et surtout
n'emprunter jamais d'argent pour jouer
et ne jouait pas en espérant regagner ce
que vous avez perdu
identifier les situations dans
lesquelles vous avez du mal à garder le
contrôle et éviter les par exemple si
vous avez tendance à jouer plus que
prévu quand vous êtes dans un bar et bas
inter des élus
et enfin écoutez vos proches ils n'ont
pas toujours raison mais ils sont plus
objectifs que vous donc s'ils sont
plusieurs à vous faire remarquer que
vous dérapez fait quelque chose
et là je vous renvoie au début de la
liste voilà et encore une fois si malgré
tout vous n'arrivez pas à garder le
contrôle
parlez-en à des professionnels il ya des
adresses utiles dans la description de
la vidéo ou la ligne de joueurs à faux
service au 09 74 75 13 13
et si rien ne marche vous pouvez aussi
demander à vous faire interdire de jeu
vous avez compris les paris sportifs les
jeux de hasard et d'argent
c'est comme tout temps que vous gardez
le contrôle et que vous faites plaisir
tout va bien mais c'est bien de rester
vigilant pour éviter les dérives voilà
détester c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez sont les autres mettez vous bien
et surtout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]